there was another democratic debate last  night things got really heated  candidates were shouting over each other  a lot of the time and it was sort of  hard to follow what they were saying and  I gotta say I don't think I was the only  one who found all of it very off-putting  check this out and yes that means the  Secretary of Education who will support  teachers that it also means investing  thank you my proposing an education we  can submit our teachers thank you know  the math does not I think we were  talking about maths and it doesn't take  two hours to do let's talk about what we  man let's talk about  listen they don't want to be out I guess  the only way you do this is jump in and  speak twice as long as you should  [Applause]